caroline oui moi je voudrais vous parler
du bio parce que c'est vrai qu'on parle
beaucoup du bio dans l'alimentation et
on préconise que les enfants quand même
mange bio de plus en plus comment on
fait quand on n'a pas les moyens d'aller
vers le bio qui coûtent un peu plus cher
alors dans ce cas là on va rester sur de
l'agriculture raisonnée on va
privilégier les petits producteurs
plutôt que les grandes surfaces où on va
aller choisir des produits qui viennent
d'espagne et d'ailleurs vont rester sur
du local voilà on prend pas bio on prend
locales au moins on est sûr et on a
confiance en nos petits producteurs qui
produisent et malgré malgré tout est ce
que vous êtes de ceux de deux de ses
chefs qui nous disent oui mais attention
si vous ne le faites ni bio ni locavore
bas vous fait mal ou bien sont gênés de
culpabiliser goris des essais importants
donc on se déculpabilise si on n'a pas
les moyens d'acheter du bio et qu'on n'a
pas le petit producteur à côté et bien
on prend son produit de l'alimentation
et de toute façon ce sera tous toujours
lutins produits transformés est-ce que
l'appartement nous qui le faisons bien
sûr c'est sa nièce d'accord tatiana les
parents qui ont un régime alimentaire
particulier notamment ceux qui mangent
des gains est ce qu'il est possible de
faire manger uniquement vegan un bébé
alors je vais m'attirer les foudres des
vegan mais c'est pas un régime qui est
adapté aux bébés parce que il exclut
trop de choses en revanche et tout ce
qui est jugé jeetoo alors ça je me dis
vraiment c'est vraiment parce qu'on va
voir que les ivg todor les végétaux
c'est tout ce que vous appelez les
drilles lait de soja qui ne sont pas des
lames et qui sont des jus oui ils sont
strictement interdits pour les bébés en
tout cas parce qu'ils n'ont pas les les
choses nécessaires pour une bonne car
ans exactement d'accord sûr que pas
vegan végétalien on peut s'adapter avec
le pédiatre et des nutritionnistes qui
nous aident donc vega vegan non
végétariens ont pesé quoi votre
différence pour nos téléspectateurs
entre vegan c'est qu'on exclut tout ce
qui vient de l'animal donc pas de beurre
pas de crème pas de l'est pas de vols a
pas de produit animal et les végétariens
on va avoir quand même de l'oeuf
on va avoir quelques produits qui sont
qui pourront quand même à faire partie
du régime alimentaire
vous nous dites à partir de quel âge on
pourrait éventuellement faire que
l'enfance ou s'accordent au régime
alimentaire des parents pour attendre
quoi six ans est en bas le plus tard
possible à ce que l'enfant il m'a pris
trois ans ils s'arrêtent pas de grandir
et continuer en pleine croissance en
pleine évolution donc aux [ __ ] plutôt
vous à les incorporer des choses qui
sont bonnes et qui sont essentiels pour
lui les protéines végétales les
protéines animales sont bonnes et sont
importantes si maintenant vous dit que
vous avez si vous les exclus et vous
allez avoir des vrais parents
vous n'êtes pas parti avait gagné ta
rien oui megan non d'accord on va
terminer avec thibault je ne suis pas
encore permet justement je voudrais
savoir quelle est la principale erreur
que commettent les parents concernant la
nourriture de leurs enfants
c'est vrai que les parents sont assez
focaliser maintenant parce qu'il ya le
manger sain absolument pas d'erreurs en
erreurs
y'a pas à dire on est des parents il
faut se faire confiance on donne ce
qu'on pense être bon à nos bébés donc il
faut pas se culpabiliser il faut pas
dramatiser
moi je vais en coaching et j'ai des
parents quand je vais chez eux ils me
disent oui j'ai fait ça et vous me dites
ça c'est pas grave
votre enfant il va bien il est en bonne
santé est ce que le real a redonné moi
c'est de sacraliser un peu trop tous les
rituels autour de la nourriture est de
faire que ça devient une obsession pour
les parents et pour l'enfant et plus
rien de naturel c'est plus rien de
naturel autour de la table et du coup ça
ça ça crée des soucis aussi bien chez
les parents que chez l'enfant
moi ce que je recommande c'est vraiment
de de ne pas stresser de se faire
confiance
celle le monde le moment du repas ce à
un moment de convivialité où on sait
plaisir et tous donc il faut faire
plaisir à nos enfants mais fo constate
plaisir aussi parce que si on en vient
un combat entre eux et nous c'est
compliqué et ni eux ni nous ni passer un
moment de plaisir
alors je sais que vous prenez pour le
fait à la maison et le fait par le papa
ou la maman avec des aliments comme ça
qu'on va acheter indépendamment les uns
des autres pour créer son sa recette
mais si par hasard on serait comme je
l'étais je le reconnais une mauvaise
mère et on va faire des petits pots ou
deux mamans avec des petits pots j'ai
grandi avec des petits formats j'ai été
élevée aux petits pots et je suis en
bonne santé et votent pas mal du tout je
suis pas mal d'accord il vous n'y avez
pas grave il faut me donner des petits
porcs parce que je voudrais
déculpabiliser aussi les parents qui
éventuellement nous regardent et allan
davis un peu compléter qui se disent bon
bah moi je fais des petits pots quoi
vaut mieux donner des petits pots à son
bébé
que ce soit justement ce moment un
moment de calvaire si ça rassure les
parents de donner des petits poèmes ep
donner des petits pois au bbq d'accord
moi je suis pas contre bien au contraire
ce qu'il ya dedans c'est bon pour eux
j'ai visité des usines qui fabriquent
des petits pots donc je peux vous
garantir que ce qu'il ya dedans c'est
bon maintenant on privilégie quand même
le fait maison parce que c'est un moment
convivial et de transmission mon passé
mon métier chef de cuisine à la fois un
moment de partage et de transmission
si vous n'avez pas me laisser l'amour et
le partage peuvent se font se montre
autrement ça se transmettra par des
petits pots c'est pas très grave
enfin merci
cdd
[Applaudissements]